hello everyone and welcome to the 9th
Python web development with flash
tutorial video in this video we're going
to be doing mostly just some
housekeeping stuff we're going to first
of all I don't want to have these
popovers everywhere so right now on
every page because this is part of the
header we have to have these and because
of that we also need to have get in post
I don't really want to be doing that but
I would like to leave it on the main
page it does look pretty I just don't
want it on every page
at least at the moment and you can write
a Python function that will populate
these when the user calls on it maybe
we'll do that too maybe I'll add it to
my site I don't know we'll see anyway
not top priority but I do at least for
now we're going to change these to head
to just slash login slash register and
we're actually going to make a page that
handles that as well well sue keep the
popovers on main but yeah also while
we're here we're going to write a
handling for 404 errors so right now 404
leads to this page which is absolutely
disgusting we want to have some handling
for a 404 and then finally we'll
probably add in flash as well flash is a
way of sending really really dynamic
messages basically to the page or to the
well yet basically to the page and then
I use some bootstrap code to make the
flash stuff dismissible it's pretty cool
so maybe add that into this one maybe in
the next video but but we'll see how we
get how far we go so anyways let's do it
so first we want to change the this
information here we're going to bring
this up we've got the header here so
this is all the header stuff support
stays the same login we're gonna get rid
of this entire div for login I just
don't want it anymore for now anyways we
might come back to it like I said don't
feel sad but anyway but and we are
leaving it on them remember we have a
main dot HTML and this is just header we
just copy and pasted the main HTML so
that's why we still have this stuff what
appears I have lost myself where
okay so did this one so we delete that
delete this and after you delete well
first we need to also delete basically
all that and then you know the role
presentation all the way to data target
so it's literally just href now and then
for login it links to slash login and
then for signup it is going to link to
register then we're going to check to
make sure everything closes this closes
but this unordered list is not closed so
I'm just going to delete it I must have
made a mistake somewhere
okay let's save that and refresh come
over here look at the bottom yep links
to login link stretch ester but of
course we have these nasty 404s so
before we add any more linkage in our
dot pi let's fix the 404 so here whoops
okay so now we've got a true this is
dashboard now we're going to handle
specifically a 404 error and the way
that we do that is actually flasks
built-in error handler so app dot uh
error and the ler
so again app is this app equals flask
name so air handler is part of flask so
app dot error handler and we want to
handle a 404 and so column and we're
just going to define page underscore not
underscore found with the e4 error and
then we're going to just let's just try
what normally when you're coding a page
I would suggest you try and except
simply because uh the error handling or
the debugging mode on flask has never
worked for me so when I write new code
on a new page of some sort I will use
try and accept and just the accept will
return the error so for example I don't
hate to do it on this but I guess I'll
show it I will try to weave that into
this this tutorial as well but anyways
let's just page not found uh let's
return 404 okay all looks well so we
save that we're going to come over here
restart Apache we'll come over to our
website let's refresh getting internal
server error on this let's review what
have we done oh oh dear okay
I knew that my eyes were like telling me
man there's something wrong what are you
doing um okay so tab that over and get
rid of this : that was dumb okay save
refresh that's so funny because like as
I was doing that was like I felt like
something was wrong
I just couldn't I couldn't pick that one
up anyway so there we have it now let's
click on any of these will 404 so click
on that and boom we have 404 obviously
that's really boring so generally what
you're going to have is like this so
we'll come over we're in templates we
can just new file 404 dot HTML and we'll
just lets take from dashboard here this
this this beginning code so copy paste
and then its end block at the very
bottom so copy that paste and then we'll
just add some paragraph tags and say
whoops that page doesn't exist and then
we'll just say 404 so save that we
shouldn't have to change anything so oh
we have to render the template so we
will have to do
we'll have to edit this and then restart
apache of course so now instead of
return 404 we return render underscored
templates and that's 404 dot HTML save
it
let's come back over here restart it
come to the website that I have lost
refresh and now we have at least a page
that keeps at least our header we just
have some paragraph text but if you look
on Python programming net
I have a really sexy snake so Python
program net / super and we get this
awesome hand-drawn snake for page not
found it's awesome
and then we even have a go back button
that goes back to where you left off Wow
fancy stuff anyway moving along so now I
got four four awesome cool uh the next
thing that what else do we want have I
remember what the other things I
promised okay so try and accept that was
another thing I promise so let's go
ahead and do a try and except real quick
so let's just make a really quick page
let's just take this page right here
let's copy this paste app root we'll use
slash board from before we'll change
this to slash board now it returns a
render template dashboard IHT ml
everything is the same
okay so first let's save it and just
make sure that we're not getting any
other errors that we have doped off and
not realized fresh cool um let's do
slash board okay that's still working so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to let's say topic dict equals a
ShamWow save and we'll come over here
we'll restart apache everything's great
we're like yeah here we go oh and we've
been gutted by this internal server
error the real error is not I mean it's
an internal server error but the real
error is that ShamWow is just simply not
fine so what really should have been
done or what could be done is the phone
because I try our hardest to return that
template but except exception as e
return the string version of that e save
that refresh come back over restart and
now we say C global name ShamWow is not
defined now we could take that even
further and we can make it pretty at
least so we could say okay well now we
can do this
new file let's make 500 on HTML just for
the record you can actually handle in a
similar manner that we've handled a 404
we can actually handle a 500 error but
it's generally not as successful for me
for some reason like sometimes I see my
500 error and I'm like yeah there it is
and then other times I don't get it so
don't know what's up there but anyway
you could do a try and except you could
have a 500 HTML it could be just like
your 404 pastes 500 yo okay so that's a
500 error 500 HTML we come back to our
innate dot pi file if that didn't work
we could return for example we'll do
this copy paste and then that's 500 HTML
and then error equals e and in fact
let's come back to where we were that's
a good idea
and then in variables we would just
let's say error okay cool
so now air or equals e which we have as
a there let's save we might have to
string e but I don't think so I think
we'll be just fine let's restart Apache
let's go to our website let's refresh
and then we get a pretty 500 error a 500
Yelp global name ShamWow is not defined
so there we have errors um as tutorials
getting kind of long so I think we'll
cut off a flash messaging but the next
video I'll show you flash messaging it's
actually pretty quick but I want to show
you how I tie it in to bootstrap because
flash is kind of uh it's meant to be
like a really just a basic you know hey
pop-up kind of message and you want the
user to be able to get rid of that
message so we tie it in to bootstrap so
I guess we'll kind of dedicate a whole
tutorial too to that as well
so anyways stay tuned for that and all
the other things
we've got coming hopefully you guys are
enjoying as always if you have any
questions or comments please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support in the subscriptions and until
next